من مقبره ابوصير شمال القاهره الى المانيا
ثم الى الولايات المتحده رحله تابوت خشبي
قديم نهب من مصر وعاد الى احضانها فبعد
سنوات من الجهود استعاده القاهره تابوت
الاخضر الذي نهبته شبكه منظمه او شبكه
منظمه عام 2016 تهريبه خارج مصر
التابوت الاخضر كنز يعود الى عصور مصر
القديمه
لكن اثريه اخرى وبعوده هذه القطاع يؤكد
المصريون انهم لن يفرطوا في حقهم على
استعاده تاريخ بلادهم من الخارج تفاصيل مع
سمر بشار
[موسيقى]
التابوت الاخضر وهكذا يعرف احد اكبر
التوابيت حيث يبلغ طوله نحو ثلاثه امتار
كان قد خرج من مصر بطريقه غير شرعيه منذ
عده سنوات
والاسترداته مصر من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث كان معروضه في متحف يسن
تابوت الخشبي ذو الوجه الملون بالاخضر
ومغطى بكتابه
مع 17 قطعه اثريه بعد تحقيقات استمرت
عامين بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا التابوت يرجع لكاهن في
منطقه مصر الوسطى عنماعه وينتمي للعصر
المتاخر
يبقى للكبار رجال الدوله وكبار الشخصيات
فواضح انه كان له علاقه طيبه جدا بالملك
او بالحاكم واضح من الحجم بتاعه اللي وصل
2 متر 94 طول في عرض 90 واضح انه كان جوه
تابوت اخر
لصوص المقابر وللاسف
استسهلوا خدوا اللبس
وتعرض ده عشان كده بقول للاسف اتعرض
لسوء معامله ادى الى تقسيم جزء من القاعده
زي ما احنا شايفين
[موسيقى]
الانفلات ايام احداث 2011 ممكن حاجات زي
كده الله اعلم دي خلي الاجابه على هذا
السؤال لجهات التحقيق
المصريه لاسترداد الاثار المسروقه
والمهربه فقد وقعت مصر على عده اتفاقات
الثنائيه مع دول العالم لاسترداد الاثار
المسروقه ومنها الولايات المتحده عام 2016
وتم تجديدها العام الماضي الى جانب
اتفاقيه اليونسكو عام 1970 لحظر الاتجار
غير المشروع للممتلكات الثقافيه ازاي
ده سؤال مهم جدا ان احنا عندنا
اليات كثيره جدا احنا اداره هي تراقب
العالم تراقب بصيلات المزادات اللي موجوده
تعرض قطعه اثريه مصريه ما يتم ضبطه في
المطارات والموانئ العالميه ما يعرض في
المتاحف والمعارض الخاصه
بالتحف والقطع الاثريه في الخارج وبنعمل
على التاكد من خروجه من مصر بطريقه غير
شرعيه من عدمه وقد استردت مصر في السنوات
الاخيره نحو 30,000 قطعه اثريه من دول
مختلفه سمر باشات لصباح العربيه من
القاهره
مصر استعاده اكثر من
29,000 قطعه اثريه لكن يبلغ عدد هذه
القطعه خارج البلاد في اقل تقدير طبقا
لاحصاءات دقيقه مليون قطعه يبقى الملف
مفتوحا سواء لجهه استعاده الاثار من
المتاحف في الخارج او وقف عمليات التهريب
فخلال عام 2022 وحده تم ضبط حواليه
3496 قطعه اثريه بالمنافذ المصريه قبل
خروجها من البلاد بطرق غير قانونيه من اهم
القطع الاثريه الفريده خارج مصر هي حجروا
رشيد حاليا في المتحف البريطاني في لندن
ايضا راس نفرتيتي التي تعرض في المتحف
المصري بالعاصمه الالمانيه برلين كذلك
تمثال وزير الملك خوفو ومهندس بناء الهرم
الاكبر يوجد حاليا هذا التمثال في المانيا
ايضا لوحه زودياك موجوده حاليا في متحف
لوفر بفرنسا وقطعه من دقن ابو الهول وتعرض
في المتحف البريطاني يوجد في مصر خمسه
مسلات بينما في روما ووحدها ثماني مسلات
مصريه تشير الاحصاءات الى ان عدد المسلات
يصل الى مئه مثلث
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا رئيس الاداره المركزيه للاثار
والاصول المتردده دكتور شعبان عبد الجواد
دكتور اسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا صباح
العربيه التابوت الاخضر يعود الى ارض
الفراعنه لو نتحدث اكثر عن تفاصيل التابوت
وكيف تسترد او طريقه البحث عن اثار
المهربه من مصر
في الحقيقه طبعا صباح الخير على حضرتك
وعلى الساده المشاهدين احنا بنحتفل في
بدايه عام 20 23 باسترداد التابوت الاخضر
وعودته مره اخرى الى الاراضي المصريه
الحقيقه طبعا مصر بتبذل جهود كبيره جدا في
عمليه استرداد الاثار ويمكن التجربه
المصريه هي تجربه فريده على مستوى العالم
وهناك الكثير من دول العالم تريد استنساخ
التجربه المصريه في عوده الاثار احنا في
عام 20 21 نجحت مصر فقط في استرداد
5,300 قطعه اثريه العامل الماضي 20 22
المنتهي منذ ايام قليله مصر استردت 106
قطعه اثريه منهم القطعه الكبيره النادره
للتبوت همم ماعد اللي هو ما يعرف بالتابوت
الاخضر هناك استراتيجيه مصريه نعمل عليها
لا نتحدث الا في ما يتم الانتهاء منه من
قضايا ولكن هناك الكثير والكثير من
القضايا لا يمكن ان نتحدث فيها الاعلام
ولكن نتحدث عنها فقط عندها همم عندما يتم
الانتهاء منها حفاظا على سريه التحقيقات
والاجراءات التي تقوم بها الحكومه المصريه
هذه الجهود مؤخرا يعني كل فتره نسمع
ويتصدر عناوي الاخبار بان مصر تريد
استرجاع الاثار لماذا في الاونه الاخيره
مصر مصره اليوم وفي هذه الفتره على
استرجاع الاثار ومجتمعه معا
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه طبعا ده سؤال همم مهم لحضرتك
هو الجهود المصريه مصر الجديده مصر بعد
ثوره 2011 همم تعمل في على كافه الجهات
على اعاده كل الحقوق الى الشعب المصري
الاثار هي ارث حضاري همم للشعب المصري
ويجب الحفاظ عليه الدستور 2014 الاستفتاء
عليه الشعب المصري همم في ثلاث مواد تنص
على حمايه الاثار والممتلكات الثقافيه
وماده من ضمن مواد القانون تنص على العمل
على استرداد ما تم تهريبه من الاثار
المصريه الى الخارج همم طبعا عندنا دلوقت
الكثير من المتاحف المصريه يكفي ان احنا
عندنا ان شاء الله قريبا افتتاح المتحف
المصري الكبير وهو من اكبر المتاحف في
الاثار المتخصصه على مستوى العالم سيكون
هديه مصر الى العالم عندنا المتحف القومي
للحضاره المصريه ومتحف يشرح تاريخ الحضاره
المصريه همم كافه الكثير والكثير من
المتاحف المجهزه والمعده الى استقبال
الاثار المصريه سواء التي خرجت همم
الحفائر او التي خرجت منه هنا السؤال يعني
مصر استعاده اكثر من 29,000 قطعه اثريه
كيف خرجت هذه الاثار من ارض الفراعنه
مصر تعرضت زيها زي كثير من الدول الى
عمليات مهبل لاثارها يعني ده موجود في كل
الدول التراثيه كل الدول اللي عندها حضاره
عانت من عمليات تهريب اثاره اليونان تعاني
من عمليات تهريب اثاره ايطاليا تعاني من
عمليات التاليه بصاره العراق سوريا ليبيا
اليمن همم دول امريكا اللاتينيه كل الدول
ال- ال- ال- التي تملك تراث حضاري تعرضت
لعمليات نهب لتراثه في فترات سابقه ومصر
كانت من ضمن الدول الحضاره المصريه تتميز
بانها حضاره فريده لا يوجد علم في العالم
اخذ اسمه من اسم بلد زي اللي جبتولوجي او
علم المصريات فهو الاثار المصريه مميزه
والعالم يتهافت عليها وفي فترات سابقه
منها فترات الاحتلال والقرنين ال 19 وال
20 تعرضت مصر الى حملات تهريب اثاره ولكن
الحمد لله مصر للطاقه في العين واقفه جدا
لاستعاده كل اثارها المعربه وما زال هناك
الكثير من القطعه الاثريه التي تنتظرها
مصر لمعرفه المزيد عن الحضاره الفرعونيه
ومفتاحها من القاهره رئيس الاداره
المركزيه للاثار والاصول المسترده الدكتور
شعبان عبد الرواد شكرا جزيلا لك